my clowns
we know Heidi Klum is the queen of
Halloween she's rocked some seriously
epic and elaborate costumes but this
year she took a different approach how
easy is it for me this year you guys I'm
so excited because I just have to go in
the shower at the end of the night
the supermodel hosted her annual
Halloween bash Monday night in New York
City Heidi stepped out on the red carpet
looking like her glamorous self only
difference she had five look-alikes by
her side everyone always says how do you
juggle it all how do you juggle it all
and you know I'm always like thinking I
wish there were more of me so I could
you know have it much easier you know
one could stay at home the other one
could go work but six times me today I
had my face passed and then all the
girls had to have their face cast and it
was very tricky because my face had to
then fit on their faces so it was very
very hard to do the mother of four also
revealed how her kids reacted when they
saw her with the rest of the high D
squad yeah they thought that it was a
lot of fun I think but that was probably
the freakiest but I could inspire people
to come up with new ideas so you're not
always the same every year and that for
me is always the biggest challenge
because I want to surprise people with
something